des poules à l'équateur des États-Unis à
la Chine la terre sufoque les journées
de mardi et mercredi ont été les plus
chaudes jamais enregistrées au niveau
mondial à cette période le réchauffement
climatique de cesse de s'accélérer on a
connu le mois de juin le plus chaud
chacun voit bien que il faut que nous
accélérions le rythme de la
décarbonation de notre économie et la
transition climatique ça coûte cher en
ce qui concerne les orages ils ont
traversé une partie de la France ce
matin du Sud-Ouest au centre et devrait
toucher le nord-est cet après-midi a
Descartes en Indre-et-Loire le toit de
l'église a pris feu nous augmenterons je
l'ai toujours dit à partir du budget
2024 la fiscalité sur toutes les
énergies fossiles le GNR affirmé que les
taxes sur les billets d'avion vont être
augmentés à partir du 1er 2021 c'est
parti des options ce changement
climatique est accompagné de phénomènes
extrêmes des pluies diluviennes en Chine
100 000 personnes le nom du être déplacé
au Niger les hommes et les animaux
paient le prix du réchauffement
l'agriculture ne résiste pas dressé
devant les forces de l'ordre entre les
manifestants et les fonctionnaires de
police les députés de la France
insoumise et d'autres élus de gauche ont
délibérément bravé l'interdiction de
rassemblement place de la République
hier en tout cas c'est une provocation
de manière évidente à partir du moment
où vous maintenez l'organisation d'une
manifestation qui a été déclarée
illégale qui a été rendu interdite
confirmer par le Conseil
d'états de la majorité qui en 2020 en
manifesté devant l'Assemblée nationale
avec des syndicats policiers factieux
pour dire que le problème de la police
était la justice c'est pas nous qui
avons fait ça
d'extrêmement internationale donc on a
aucune leçon à recevoir de ces gens là
veulent gouvernement si ce n'est une
provocation alors je vous le dis on va
pas y céder on va se rassembler ici
place de la République à hauteur que
nous voulons la France insoumise utilise
cet argument là pas de la faute
politique mais de volontairement aller
dans des manifestations illégales pour
essayer de faire croire que nous
vivrions ici en France dans un pays
autoritaire parce qu'aujourd'hui on a un
clientélisme à gauche pas simplement les
filles mais dans toute la nuit passe qui
mettent leur lunettes de société
communautariste puisqu'on a vu Mathilde
pano nous expliquer que le jeune n'était
pas un jeune français mais un jeune
Arabe vous détestez la police m'a-t-il
panneau comme le disait ces manifestants
vous nous avez entendu chanté ce slogan
monsieur Duhamel non mais vous ne
quittez pas non plus la manifestation
quand on est dans un rassemblement et
qu'il y a ce type de slogan si on n'est
pas d'accord on s'en va je pense que
vous n'avez pas été en manifestation
depuis longtemps je vais vous apprendre
quelque chose après un rassemblement qui
s'est déroulé dans le calme
la braven procède à l'arrestation de
Youssouf le frère d'Adama Traoré une
interpellation musclée
le Traoré il a pas beaucoup de courage
parce qu'il s'en prend à une femme
commissaire de police à qui il a fait un
tête-à-tête comme on dit un front et
qu'il a mal mené avec un lieutenant de
police de gardiens de la paix
[Applaudissements]
il a été plaqué sur le ventre avec trois
policiers sur lui comment peut-on
imaginer comment peut-on imaginer que ce
soit un geste anodin de la part de la
police comment peut-on imaginer qu'il
n'y ait pas là une provocation pour dire
que du jour au lendemain cela pourrait
se reproduire dans le groupe on a
rebaptisé en groupe que je préside la
rebaptiser la France insoumise la France
incendiaire
donc on retrouve dans
qui devrait nous alerter c'est pourquoi
est-ce que les gens disent alors
attendez parce que
du lien entre la police et la population
qui est dramatique dans ce pays un
décret publié ce matin au Journal
officiel interdit dès aujourd'hui et
jusqu'au 15 juillet inclus pour les
particuliers la vente le port et
l'utilisation d'articles pyrotechnique
sur l'ensemble du territoire autre
annonce la mise en place d'une amende
forfaitaire pour les mineurs qui
commettrait des dégradations mesure déjà
évoquées par Emmanuel Macron on veut des
réponses très rapides que les familles
mesurent les conséquences des actes
commis par leurs enfants un front âgé de
deux ans et demi est porté disparu
depuis hier soir au Vernet dans les
Alpes-de-Haute-Provence selon les
premiers éléments l'enfant a été signalé
disparu par les grands-parents alors
qu'ils se trouvaient dans le jardin de
leur domicile 4000 pieds de cannabis
soit plus d'une tonne découvert cette
semaine au terme de huit mois d'enquête
dans un entrepôt situé dans le petit
village de Morette en Isère 6 personnes
originaires de Grenoble et d'Albanie ont
été interpellés
d'inattention le petit garçon a disparu
les recherches ont commencé désir soir
elles se poursuivent ce matin